hello and welcome to this video this
will be the third episode our from the
modern classics serious and in fact this
is real IAM compared to the others
rather new game it's from 2009 from the
bill grandmaster tournament and we've
got the matchup between Alexander
Milosevic and Maxime Mahela gras from
France and this is really a breathtaking
game if you don't know it yeah you're in
for a treat
I really remember when I when I first
saw this game that I absolutely didn't
believe this was this was really played
because it's so it's so extraordinary
even what what happened here um in fact
on this game also
yeah gives me gives me a problem and in
a way because because I want to present
it because it simply belongs into this
the series but one fits the problem is
it is rather long game and it's super
complicated so it's not so easy to judge
what kind of variations to show and what
kind of stuff to to do in a more brief
fashion so that this video won't be two
hours long so um once in a while it's
just good to to get to look at the game
and take it for its yeah for it's um
esthetical sort of well um not trying to
understand each line to the length to
the last movement so I'm just yeah just
um take it as it was played and I'd
enjoy it so I might as well leave one or
two variations out of this video you
want to dig deeper than feel free to do
so it's certainly rewarding alright so
let's start it's one e-form yeah maro
plays all kinds of openings here in fact
them we've got a sharp main line in
Sicilian
and get some night off which I recently
um yeah made the some made a video on
30-minute video overview of the night
off in this opening Sun Cavett series
here um melosa which goes for f3 d6
Bishop III so this is some the
introduction to them to the English
attack the so-called English attack
because of the Yujin success that
various English players sound like a nun
short Mary Chandler and in the early
ages and it's still one of the absolute
main lines of the of the night off so
White's ideas to to set up this G form
advance with f3 and one difference to
lots of other lines in the night of us
that is f3 move protects a form really
am in a very reliable way so like
doesn't have quick count to play against
the c4 pawn which often happens if white
Dwight goes F form so white has some
some freehand with play on the flanks as
we see here really quickly form like
invests one move to play h6 preventing
the media g5 of course this is always
debatable because it also weakens
squares especially g6 you'll see that
later in the game at Trillium it really
is a weakened weaknesses g6 square long
castle and before yeah black has various
alternatives I think you can also play
Bishop d7 instead but I don't want to
get into a detailed opening discussion
um because the game is so complicated
later Queen c7 yeah here I think
theoretically white could could take the
pawn but ypres Priam prefers to to get
some some active moves going so plays H
form
yeah preparing um h v g5 sorry g5 of
course and one ideas also to get this
move Bishop h3n2 to look
the e6 pawn likes g5 and then
sacrificing only six yeah black plays d5
now counterplay in the center and yeah
this is the first important position of
this game because it's a major parting
of the ways and white now really am
yeah place who plays the first
particular move how to in general how to
just judge this position yeah blacks
king is in the center this is some the
main point here he hasn't yet to move
this Bishop and prepared castling the
question is also if castling really
really helps much because g5 is very
quick so on it's really a very concrete
um Bethel now between yeah White's
playing the sent and the Kings side with
blacks King being in the middle and
blacks play on the Queen side he can
sometimes increase pressure here get a
knight here probably more likely the
route will be M from me v not from b6
and so it's very sharp
and now morose which plays Knight f4
which is quite funny because that
immediately it just walks into this this
fork but it has something he has a very
concrete idea of course white wants to
smash on e6 so it's very difficult for
black to to not play e5 now and this was
a novelty at this point so holograph
really had to to solve this now he he
rides and his annotations that he had
them something prepared but he forgot it
and needed to find it all over again at
the end he played f5 and really AM set
up this fork winning a piece um if like
it doesn't do that it it could could go
like this let's say black takes on e4
then white would sacrifice on e6 don't
want to analyze this
super deeply just show em what kind of
position we would get not if eight and
here probably night recaptures it's um
it's it's very very hard to tell
and now something like this if you
something like this and now white will
have threads here Bishop to c4 probably
sometimes even to b5 Andrew P one so
blacks King is some it's wide open in
the middle and white has some pretty
clear compensation it's really hard to
tell why just at least in a practical
game I would take white yeah any day
because he simply has the more concrete
term threads he and the center against
the King so we decided at the end to
play e5 yeah of course
White's idea was to get a knight to a
six so there's no way back Knight to d6
and yeah the first piece sacrifice like
like takes it of course Knight takes and
Queen a5 this is really the only move
you need to get some counter play here
against a2 and then the King then if
black captures on a two there's
immediate counter play with Queen a1 and
some instance even even threatening
checkmate
so black needs to get some play on his
own yeah Queen a5 and now simply he
takes d5 White's white takes and this
has some has various ideas one ideas to
get a piece to g6 this is what I
mentioned before this h6 move really
weakens g6 so if what would get a queen
to g6 this would be em yeah probably
fatal for black or Bishop only six on g6
could also be a very nice but the queen
is really the the piece that wants to go
down we see this immediately like an out
took on a two and Queen Queen to d3 was
that the reply intending this this check
yeah and this is
a super-important position here where
now black made a mistake but of course
this to play this over the border sound
obviously super difficult he played the
move King f7 which doesn't look look
illogical or something it's a pretty
yeah plausible move covering the g6
square to prevent Queen g6 but this is
the sole this entire position is of
course simply a matter of of calculation
and it's very difficult we can look at a
couple of alternatives simply because
they're very interesting to look at what
else could black play let's say you
would play King seven let's start with
this sort of moving the King before this
checker is coming or maybe trying to
even escape here then white has the
winning move d6 and this is really am
yeah immediately winning King here is
answered by Quincy four and this is
really funny you need to take now and
all these pieces all these squares are
covered so black needs to play this
desperado here which which even loses
the rook in the corner so wide simply
wins with them yeah an exchange are
banned a winning attack and everything
at all at once so so you cannot cannot
really take this so what else you need
to go here but this is in fact quite
similar just play Quincy form this is
really as strong resource black needs to
exchange and now you threaten all kinds
of discoveries
if King to g6 then white has the strong
continuation h5 King edge seven and g5
and there's nothing that I can do your
friend g6 with yeah with me to come and
the night
hanging if you take to take here this is
also also simply lost probably you've
got where you've got something better
even King h6 maybe something like this
is even stronger so blankets black is
really just losing King e7 loses the
game with with 36 Quincy force turkey
there yeah what should black play
actually yes only one is maybe two
playable moves another play will move
this to the movie form which is rather
typical trying to block this diagonal
with e4 white will probably answer Queen
deform this seems to be a the strongest
reply taking is not really really too
great because if you would take Black
has this strong move and he will even
possibly have the chance to take take
the c6 Knight this is what would help
enormously and assaults of Queen e1 so
this is really stupid
need to go to deform and this is quite
interesting now probably this is play
with a black but it's it's tricky let's
say Bishop e6 Bishop to c4 and yeah here
black cam must play this move it's a bit
strange looking but you need to go down
here would go here and you have you have
your queen trapped it's not entirely
clear in fact this variation can
continue Queen a1 and Bishop e5 white
screen hasn't got a his squares as well
but b3 is seems to be better okay let's
just accept it for the momentum that
this is better and then after some more
luck F form this is really a mess
what yeah a sec refines the piece and
it's got all kinds of active pieces but
yeah it's super difficult to to judge
this position let's say something like
this here how would you assess this
really difficult in a practical game
this one is hanging and where should the
King go White's King is also not yeah
not super safe safely tucked away
somewhere but black doesn't have any
attacking pieces and this white
certainty ass can push all kinds of
stuff yeah
it's a very very tricky probably the
best move is this position or would have
been Bishop to b7 and this is very very
tricky White has two principal ideas you
can give this check on g6 queen g6 or I
can play g5 both are interesting let's
say queen g6 check this look so like the
most normal move King e7 p g6 check King
e6 and Bishop h3 this is the kind of
move where you would first think okay
the g5 is a deadly threat here blacks
King looks really in miserable shape but
a black can like and save himself with
check looking here and now I'm simply
back to a5 this check has made this pawn
unprotected
so if white now would play g5 black and
simply take it it still looks that looks
a bit for carriers in the center but
there's no there
to win anymore so what white should
probably play his to just returned and
now threatened g5 with made again so
that black is forced to give this check
again and we have a perpetual funny
enough so Queen g6 seems to lead to to a
draw what white could do is I could
after it should be seven he could play
g5 and this is some very complicated
black would would answer if or probably
and then it and you can continue with
various lines Queen d4 or even Queen or
even ninety-seven is an idea I don't
want to get into this too deeply it's
probably um unclear this position let's
hello unclear it's the kind of
assessment you give if you don't have
enough time but simply I don't want to
make this video I'm like two hours long
black I'm really am should play Bishop
d7 in this position or a phone both are
are interesting the king f7 move that he
played probably loses I said probably
because well the this is just so
insanely complex that you can easily
miss sir misjudge something burrows
which now played g5 which seems to be
the the best smooth night to d8 also
some move that you need to calculate but
it doesn't seem to lead to much but I
can play here knight c6 check and even
run to d6 and it's it's quite funny like
an really advanced with the King here
Knight takes before isn't good because
of check end and Queen takes that's
really am why didn't make any any
progress here
this night check simply em isn't the
best move what tomorrow plate here g5 is
is perfectly all right yeah like now
took on d5 and here white needs to find
a good move otherwise this this attack
simply needs to nothing he played the
very strong move Bishop 83 and this oops
this wasn't planned
I just wanted to paint the screen the
Snider's of course the the key attacker
here and wide simply covers the support
piece and threats are multiple something
like this is the possibility town and of
course this kind of idea with Knight
dadss strengthened now yeah what should
like do after King f7 which as mentioned
really it was a mistake
black is probably lost in this position
but it's not at all easy and we see this
game has got many twists and turns
um what black played now is he took on
e3 it certainly makes sense to to
liquidate one attack him an alternative
what she calculated was this move trying
to get rid of the night but this doesn't
seem to work the problem is and this is
really a cool line he saw this in the
game the black player I'm I mostly rely
on this his some annotations until he
saw this line during the game which is
remarkable Kingdom King to g8 King to EA
doesn't have because of Queen g6 so here
white takes takes and here the really
strong move as bishop f1 and he saw this
and the game this I think is remarkable
we should have one is super strong the
ideas
Quincy for the Queen exchange in fact is
very strong here because white
has an excellent the tech even with with
Queens off in fact black is probably
close to lost in this position at least
he will loosen the exchange I give you
just one one sample line let's say I'm
Bishop somewhere checking the snide and
you've got something like this coming
and Blackwell loose the exchange he
cannot really go here as some oops yes
this is even worse
checking g7 and g8 black will lose
material here and if he plays some
something else let's say yeah let's say
this move this is it's quite tricky
just kind of move but here white will
will have really strong attack the
problem is simply you have this instant
threat here checkmate and the problem is
simply this rook on h8 doesn't play at
all whites the check will be decisive I
think it's really remarkable that he saw
this this Bishop f1 move very strong so
I'm black cannot play this this move
which she had intended before and then
took on e3 so what now y-term gave this
check which is the strongest move and
now King e7 which seems best King e8
looking a bit strange but you need to
calculate really all moves in these kind
of positions white can take what the
check King d8 and believe me it's not so
easy to kill this at first it looks like
insane for black but it's not that you
can ya win um super easily the best move
Bishop takes e8 and after King takes
it's easy and white will invite will
what will win something like this will
lead to lead to a mate I guess yeah
exactly yeah this this is over you can
also simply take the row cantilever of a
mating attack so after Bishop takes
black in fact needs to play this this
funny move and this is answered by I
guess Bishop e6 right there should be
six yeah and this this should win for
white you get this get this back end
have a strong attack come to boot
something like this even though I don't
have an extra pawn but this is simply
too much
the King in the middle and you've got
really a strong attack with opposite
colored bishops the white squares I'm a
terrible so what should William this
means oops sorry I hit the wrong button
now this means that after the check on
the aid this is the game position yeah
you know I can easily get your head a
bit dizzy in this game this is the game
position so black went to e7 which is
which is better poses more problems the
winning it's so lost yeah but it poses
my problems
96 check this is good King f7 and here's
the first position where white missed a
concrete win but this is such a such a
weird move that it's not weird but it's
it's not at all easy to find and the
point at
that you need to see is simply amazing
so not much to blame
what morosa which played is g6 that's
chalice first and this is a strong move
which probably wins the game but he
could have played the amazing move
Bishop to e6 check and this is simply a
simply beautiful giving this check note
that there's a queen on a2 so black has
two possibilities to take this it's um
it's it's a double attack in a way yeah
but black so black needs to take it and
you first you've got a simple line
queenie 698 is rather simple forking and
this kind of stuff
it's just winning for white at first you
might think okay you've got three pieces
for the Queen but this King is some quw
one survives this because the pieces
don't coordinate at all
White has this kind of attacking ideas
this whoops then hanging white is
winning and this was not certainly what
Milosevic saw what made him consider a
different move the problem is of course
king takes and yeah this continues Queen
g6 check this is easy it certainly saw
that not f6 the only move takes yeah now
white takes threatens all kinds of stuff
so black needs to it's too weak to
capture Queen a check King f5 and maybe
he calculated up to this point or even a
bit a bit further but there's a movement
which can easily be missed ninety forms
the first tricky move I guess he still
saw that but then you might see okay
King f4 how do I continue now and this
is really cool
the king of F on f4 how do you continue
how do you continue now and in fact
there is a win but it's not at all easy
here at
white has a beautiful finishing move and
this is rooted tea form yeah this is one
of those one of those first fantastic
moves that you hardly can can see him in
advance the ideas of black takes simply
just like it was with the with a knight
then there's something
Queeny for mate very nice so you cannot
take this rook but what also has a
direct threat and this is the knight g3
checkmate and black simply has no
defense but this is a move you I mean
what what human player
I mean is it simply it's simply
unbelievable if you would see this
beforehand and I guess this is what what
he overlooked because you can easily get
to the conclusion that you have yet
white has sacrificed to pieces and
sometimes in those position it is simply
a draw because you don't have enough
firepower left - to win and also black
hands counter play now with the Queen a1
at least so you need to do something
dramatic here but probably he didn't see
this so so Bishop e6 was the win here
which he didn't see but well what he
played g6 also joins the game but it's
it's simply longer and not as concrete
but I don't see any human player playing
Bishop e6 really it's easy if you sit
there with a computer but it's entirely
different in an actual game note that if
like would would advance to f6 then it's
also considerably easier now like will
get mated very nice all pieces
help very nice made so black cannot
advance with the King he really needs to
go to g8
and this certainly was morozova the idea
in this position white only needs to get
in some check on this diagonal and it's
really chick made yeah it's really close
to checkmate so um he thought Lee had
this this in mind and if you look what
what's happening now you see that you
completely judged this correctly it is
winning the other continuation only
would have been quicker so Queen takes
e3 here and black plays Bishop to c5
that's not much else really need to get
your stuff out and here played Queen to
e4 which is strong there was an
alternative which is which also won
again Bishop e6 but also I'm not at all
easy to to see the easy the easy part is
to see this year queenie 625
I guess this he saw pretty quickly as
night c5 rook the a justice again a
checkmate note that this pawn is really
a monster he certainly saw this but the
problem is to continue after a move like
Bishop boom to be seven how do you
continue here in fact 97 check King f8
rook d7 wins and probably he overlooked
something in this line King g8 back
check and now rook t1 probably some some
of this moves them he didn't see but
okay what he played is still winning
this is not Queen e4 is some a good
human move and that it is winning so I'm
it doesn't make much sense to to do yeah
long criticism on this you can be glad
to that you find some win in this
position because it's so complicated
okay 9 f8 was played you need to lend
some support to the king and especially
cover is six to make sure that
there's no deadly check coming rook to
b8 strong pinning the night and getting
these mating ideas and to play a black
plate but should be same now that does
one there's not much else okay no more
Rosa which took on on a eight he had a
good alternative and in fact a winning
alternative I think this is the only
spot I'm here in the game where I think
he really must find this because it's
it's not really really difficult it
could take on f80 and this is what this
would win the point is if black takes
with the bishop then there's simply
Queen e5 and as mentioned this Redis is
immensely strong there's simply no way
to to defend this Bishop c8 White has
Queen to d8 and this is this is winning
ninety-seven aside the made threat so
this is from a player of morosa which
close relatively easy to see I'm not
quite sure what he what he missed the
other recaptures are not much not better
in any way let's say let's say rook
takes can also simply take and then and
threaten the Sun which should be six and
sound
it's simply over was also something like
this it's winning with 97 coming this
king is dead with the the Buried rupee
on on a Jade so taking on f8 was was
really relatively simply win a simple
win but he took on a eight is still
winning it's still winning but it gets
more and more difficult but okay
the the defensive idea that now like put
up as some is also out of this world
so Bishop takes and now Morrow played
age five so what he played what he did
here is basically playing it in a young
let's say in a sort of positional way he
set up these two pawns and these two
points killed this rook on h8 and in in
in combination with this bishop also
this Knight is is basically dead so it's
a it's very very difficult stuff for
black and probably am probably still
lost
h5 is very strong yeah and now I'm why
Sheila graph comes up with an amazing
defense of concept he simply can't
simply yeah yeah he just saw okay and
need to get rid of this this this mating
idea it's still a mate if there's a
check coming against the Queen check may
don't have seven I need to get rid of
this and the only way to do that is to
give me some square on h8 so he played
the stunning move rook h7 simply putting
this rook on pre and this way giving
himself a flight square it looks
completely weird but you need to do that
otherwise you'll get mated it's just a
matter of time and of course it's a
losing for black but this is by far the
toughest defense and really as a
stunning move through kh7 it puts after
the toughest defense simply okay what
moral did is play rook e1 this simply it
protects ro Korea because Queen a one
was threatened so this protects the rook
and black really doesn't have much
choice he took on c6 if you do something
else let's say King to h8 what can take
here
and the tech also this c5 Bishop it's
it's too much
note that white doesn't take the rook it
really would be bad to take it because
some black then is some is in a way out
of his entanglement he can then move
these pieces again at least the pieces
says he's got left so you can take it
but you can take this rook all the time
you don't need to take it immediately
yeah black as mentioned took here King
edge eight would have lost to Queen e5
so Bishop c6
Queen c6 and Bishop deform very logical
also getting some play on b2 here and
the critical squares are all covered by
by the Queen and the Snider's covering
is six okay yeah here is some a moment
where white I'm still could have one and
I think this is probably the last spot
weh-weh could could win and this is with
the prophylactic move in a way King you
won the idea being Bishop here and then
Bishop f5 the ideas to also give this
possibility regrouping this this Bishop
the amazing thing is after Bishop to c3
that white can continue into e2 because
Bishop II won Quincy 8 is actually
winning with them the idea to reroute
this Bishop there's no way I can do
anything against and also this move now
really is a threat so white is white is
completely winning these where these
lines are really insane I mean playing
this in a real game of chess between two
human beings certainly and very very
difficult so yeah King D one was was was
a good movie what burrows which played
them assimilate with King to detune
Queen here and Queen check King edge a
yeah look this rook is buried alive and
you cannot in any way secure it as
blankets it simply simply funny but it
doesn't make much sense for why to take
it also because it would just help like
to free up his pieces note that Black
has some some counter play I mean stuff
like this is a threat need to take this
into account
yeah this is what Amorosa which played
King forward getting out of this thread
I just I just had shown yeah black
doclet a5 Queen a4 a3 check was an
interesting alternative and here's
another critical position it seems that
the the move that Muro Muro switch
played now is a mistake but yeah
it's very very difficult it seems that
the toughest trial was f4 here trying to
undermine this Bishop it's quite funny I
white is playing basically with the rook
and the bishop up or let's say rook up
yeah these bishops are both into play
Age 3 and d 4 but this is an extra look
in a way because those pieces are not
moving it's it's simply great but it's
not at all clear this King is also not
great on d3 and black has got this
counter play with the apron so f4 some
really I think I moved to speed up here
in the center and trying to get this a
bishop on the phone yeah to dislodge it
from before then it doesn't have such a
good post there so f4 what would would
be it would be good but it's it's simply
very very tricky the ideas on
Bishop 2f to that this is even a good
move and who is supposed to see that the
point is if black takes then you can
take this and note that there's a check
made on g8 yeah and black is toast now
King takes this person oops
Bishop f5 check and Knight eggs does
check on on c8 winning so this is just
one idea black doesn't need to play em
bishop f2 there are other moves like
Quincy 3 let's put this on the board
quickly Quincy 3 check takes takes and
Bishop reform and this should should win
the game really black cannot take here
this is the problem because this is even
made inmate next move on to moves it's
simply a prison for the king of this
this whole configuration so f4 was was
close to winning out so so kingly to
wasn't even too bad sorry this was still
ok probably what he played was Quincy 8
which now gives black some play king to
e4 and b3 yeah yeah it simply needs to
protect this fill this night on f8 it's
all hanging by a thread
this is this kind of this position why
took and now a form also strong yeah
right now played rugby 1 which is
probably ok if white would take just to
look at this for once you can look at
this in all and it basically all and in
every position since move from 27 for
for nine loops alrighty this is a smooth
was saying and this loop was saying but
in this concrete position for example if
white would take um black would have
interesting counter play with this move
checking this this rook and far and
especially threatening discoveries
you couldn't take the rope with the
Queen because of queen evade but you
threatened the discoveries and look at
look at this position it's really
amazing Black has a very very dangerous
counter play with the pawn and it's not
obvious how I should win here in fact
after oopsie for it this would probably
end in a draw about the petrol so really
insanely complicated what white would
play this say look b1 which is probably
okay Queen before was now played note
that both players players weren't
time-traveling it's almost goes without
mention because how would you play this
such a game and have time left it's
simply I'm simply insane what see on the
clock is of course bogus is just what
what the software is giving me but I
don't have the original times Queen
before and now quit the C form yeah of
course black cannot afford to um to
exchange Queen cm need to get counter
play or give checks but to be more exact
you need to give checks so we've got a
repetition here and black now tries to
to set more problems he played Queen to
d2 with this this intention for the
moment this night is not attacked and
here it's move forty the notorious move
forty here burrows which makes a mistake
the first I mean you can talk about
mistakes if you don't win the game I
don't find the winning move but this is
really a really costly move now move
forty what he probably should do is play
Queen to c8 attacking the knight and
this seems to secure draw Queen d2 check
King to d5 Queen b5 this is a perpetual
24 and Queen e2 check this is what why
should should try now what he played but
of course it's a insanely difficult
he played Queen Bishop to g4
and this overlooked a strong move for
black this is a three and this is more
40 he probably found this with the last
seconds on the clock and now black has
got a very strong play with the apron
and there's simply no mate I mean
there's nothing but white can can do at
the moment let's see it it's really
tried everything everything to to fight
but it's now really really really
difficult Queen f7 to Quincy to check
King up no choice and Queenie always
check so this Knight is defended again
King e4 and a to the a pawn really AM
gets the honors here
Roxy one and A one Queen rook c5 Bishop
c5 so this Bishop now can can cover and
white now is some is the night and to
look down and it's still not completely
easy because this is not a real rook
right it's still yeah there for the
taking and also this Knight cannot move
let's move
let's advance a couple of moves white
plate a queen to d5 Queen e1 check got a
couple of checks in King to c4 and black
exchange Queens so take a look at this
position neck as a rook up and a knight
up but is it so easy to win this
position this Knight cannot move I mean
it can but I would just take it and how
do you how do you get your workout on h7
this is also hanging on c5 and this is
why am I still a graph now played Bishop
e3 very year and the
then they will move in fact here we had
yet a better and easier win with Knight
takes g6 this wasn't easy to see though
the ideas take here and then h5 which is
a pretty really remarkable idea really
to free the the rook and this is
probably winning you need to assess this
position here here and why it still has
some play with the beep on that black
will be quick enough to to get behind it
and then he has this pawn switch will
win against the the bishop
so here Knight takes g6 would have won a
bit easier and he played Bishop e3 and
now very strong push up f5 and yeah how
does black win now if you look at this
this position let's say let's say let's
continue let's continue and I can show
you the idea in the game played King to
g8
kingi v King d5 oops sorry
a king e5 Ruge h8 and King be 5 so take
a look at this position how should black
get his pieces out it's really funny
just for example if black would take now
on g6 I would recapture King f8 and King
e6 and this is simply a dead wrong it's
completely completely dead draw what
white would do will do now I will just
play King e6 to d7 and I can do this
yeah until I'm old and grave I mean it's
it's a it's simply a draw it's it's a
kind of fortress black cannot win
there's simply no no idea even um it's
funny that the computers to give this +4
for black it simply cannot see that this
is this is dead that drawn yeah
computers still don't understand
fortresses
so quite funny Nagi sixsome is bad so so
what what should like do he actually
found found a good good way a good a
good way to play the scene we need to
play the smooth need to put another
piece on prion h7 which is simply great
and I love this game rook h7 it was
hanging there for 20 moves almost 24
moves and now you need to put another
piece on prion h7 and it's the only way
to win this game you need to do that
and I mean okay you can do maybe one
move later or something but this is the
winning idea everything else doesn't win
okay why takes it came here check enter
King f6 and in fact this isn't
completely easy because look at this
pawn this kind of configuration bishop
on g6 and porn on h7 how should black
play that allows him to activate his own
rook to somewhere else than the
eighth-ranked because immediately if you
go to a 1 or somewhere else then this
pawn will promote how would you cover
this square it's not at all easy
it's the lamb a matter of form of good
technique the video is already pretty
long so I'll go through this where she
played this ex excellent deep here found
them the way to do this and this is Zeus
one let's advance a couple of moves
what black needs to do he needs to ok
first him got this pawn and at the end
of this one
me too yeah ok you can move on the
eighth-ranked as I mentioned
the problem is that at one point we see
this and this is also here this is what
I mentioned this is this is a zoomin
position
what should should Y do now the problem
is that he needed to play play this move
you cannot avoid what this move as king
to be seven lose this to um what was it
King to be seven losses to I don't I
don't have a note on this this is funny
okay
it's Bishop e5 yeah yeah now I
understand it you don't even need to
know sometimes you can even find
something yourself the problem is now
you you will get into Zeus wrong here as
well rook b8 is coming rook b8
and king king on the side the problem is
if white moves the bishop which she did
now and he didn't really have a choice
as mentioned then he had black had the
chance soo and he did play g5 and this
is the important move this bishop is now
covering h8 white needs to take up a
song very funny
poor information but now the bishop is
the piece that controls those pawns and
you can move the rook freely so a couple
of games a couple of their moves were
played but this is not winning with King
to e7 and rook b8 checkmate
yeah really an amazing game I saw that
the video no it's about 15 minutes and
you could easily do 2 hours on that
really fascinating game I remember that
in one of Germany's some tough chess
magazines this game had of course
title title um a picture titled diagram
the diagram yeah abroad yeah bought with
the position with the rook on h7 and
this is what titled this is why we
played this is why we play chess yeah
and this is a pretty pretty fitting
title for this game it's simply amazing
to to see that black rook was hanging
there for 24 moves on h7 and some
amazing lines also in them so great yeah
compliments to both players for for
creating such an outstanding game very
great absolutely great defense with rook
age seven and of course great attacking
play it just wasn't meant to be it seems
that Rose which wins the scam yet quite
a number of good opportunities but
didn't didn't really find the the
finishing blow it was winning for a long
time but at the end he faltered probably
in time travel with this Bishop g4 move
yeah thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed this game it's certainly one of
the most complicated games that that I
did them up to now in this channel I
hope you have yeah I didn't get get too
dizzy while watching this yeah thanks
Adam
I'll be back soon with new videos